[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit niki serien freut mich dass
sie dabei sind in allen einen schönen
guten abend alles wichtige vom sport
heute von und mit kristin otto sehr gern
genannt dann schauen wir uns jetzt
gemeinsam den themen überblick an
letzte ausweg in der pandemie politik
und wissenschaft diskutieren über eine
impfpflicht gegen korona
schaulaufen für den cdu-vorsitz
kanzleramtschef braun und friedrich merz
werden um die mitglieder
anschlag oder unfall in den usa rast ein
geländewagen in eine weihnachtsparade
und tötet fünf menschen
[Musik]
drastischer als die kanzlerin kann man
es eigentlich kaum formulieren wir haben
eine lage die alles übertreffen wird was
wir bisher hatten was jetzt gilt reicht
nicht aus sagte merkel heute im
cdu-vorstand gleichzeitig wird über eine
generelle impfpflicht diskutiert während
die ampel parteien in der sache eher
ablehnend sind können sich das immer
mehr unionsgeführte bundesländer einfach
an bayern sehr gut vorstellen aber auch
baden württembergs ministerpräsident
kretschmann von den grünen wird der
spiekermann
markus söder bayerns ministerpräsident
fordert jetzt die allgemeine impfpflicht
also für alle nur teilweise nur für
mitarbeitende in heimen und kliniken die
noch am donnerstag von den ländern
gefordert aus seiner sicht geht das
nicht eine partielle impfpflicht zum
einen einmal schafft ungerechtigkeiten
warum nur eine berufsgruppe warum nicht
alle was wo ist dann der nutzen auf
dauer die impfpflicht hilft uns nicht in
der jetzigen krise aber sie wird uns auf
dauer helfen wir müssen aus der
endlosschleife raus rückendeckung
bekommt söder aus baden württemberg vom
grünen ministerpräsidenten winfried
kretschmann
eine impfpflicht ist kein verstoß gegen
die freiheitsrechte vielmehr ist sie die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir unsere
freiheit zurückgewinnen die möglichen
ampelkoalition ehre im bund befürworten
inzwischen recht geschlossen eine
teilweise impfpflicht in bestimmten
einrichtungen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht halten wir für
verfassungswidrig allerdings prüfen wir
gerade sehr intensiv eine impf
nachweispflicht für
risikobereiche also krankenhäuser alten-
und pflegeheime wir als spd
bundestagsfraktion können uns eine
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
vorstellen das betrifft auch die frage
kitas und schulen diese diskussion
führen wir jetzt und wir sollten hier
sehr zeitnah zu einem ergebnis kommen
jens spahn geschäftsführender
bundesgesundheitsminister hatte sich
wiederholt gegen eine allgemeine und
auch gegen eine teilweise impfpflicht
ausgesprochen er bleibt auch heute
skeptisch gleichzeitig sehe ich meine
aufgabe als geschäftsführerin der
minister im übergang dass wenn die neues
ich finde mehrheit
und bittet einen gesetzentwurf zu
erarbeiten der jetzt das umsetzt was am
donnerstag vereinbart wurde eine
verpflichtende impfung in bestimmten
berufsgruppen dass wir natürlich diesen
gesetzentwurf für diese
parlamentarische mehrheit erarbeiten an
dieser mehrheit arbeiten die künftigen
ampelkoalition ehre eine impfpflicht für
alle wie sie jetzt von einigen
ministerpräsidenten gefordert wird dafür
sehen sie keinen spielraum
also eine scheidende regierung und eine
mögliche die sich noch vor mir die
kanzlerin spricht von einer hoch
dramatischen lage und der bahn ag in
berlin eine schwierige situation für die
künftigen koalitionäre was können sie
tun in diesem zwischenstadium also vor
allem können sie sich möglichst schnell
auf einen koalitionsvertrag einigen denn
solange der nicht steht so erleben wir
dass gerade hier in berlin gibt es immer
nur sehr vorsichtige und langsame
äußerungen von den drei parteien die
davon handeln auch zur politik
allerdings darf man nicht erwarten das
wenn der koalitionsvertrag dann steht
und wenn eine regierung aus den ampel
parteien steht dann wirklich härter
schneller durchgegriffen wird wie das
jetzt manche heute fordern sondern da
muss man eben wieder sehen da kommen
drei parteien zusammen die große
unterschiede vertreten und überbrücken
müssen auch in der korona politik die
fdp die immer wieder den
freiheitsbegriff sehr betont hat die spd
die die alten chor ohne regeln
mitverantwortet hat und die grünen die
diese coroner regeln er mit unterstützt
haben in der vergangenheit also da wird
es noch viel abstimmungsbedarf geben in
jedem einzelnen schritt in dieser
pandemie aber vielleicht wird er dann
immerhin schneller öffentlich und
deutlicher kommuniziert komplizierte
phase und ausgangslage danke nach berlin
chuck und einen lichtblick gibt es
jedenfalls die zahl der impfungen
fakt aber wieder gibt es verunsicherung
der gesundheitsminister hat nämlich
angekündigt mehr moderner staat bei
montech bei den impfungen einzusetzen
csu-chef sondern ahnte die kommunikation
heute desaströs jens spahn verteidigte
sich und seinen kurs nochmal aber viele
ärzte finden diesen kurs ziemlich
problematisch
ostern noch vor weihnachten bei doktor
stiller ist es im moment noch nur bei
montech er impft im schnitt höchstens 18
mal am tag moderner einzusetzen heißt
für die hausärzte viel wegzuwerfen wir
haben sechs spritzen in der regel aus
dem well herauszuziehen und bei moderner
würden es 20 ergeben die verbraucht
werden müssen und das sprengt die praxis
logistik bei den meisten nicht zu ende
gedacht meint der praktische arzt und
empfiehlt berlin solle doch die
rationierung von beyond eck für
arztpraxen zurücknehmen und moderner
lieber großflächig an wieder öffnete
impfzentren liefern in berlin bot jens
spahn heute die höchstdosis an experten
auf um gegen die nebenwirkung seiner
entscheidung anzukämpfen die allgemeine
impfstoff verunsicherung moderner ist
ein guter sicherer und sehr wirksamer
impfstoff manche impfenden ärzte sagen
biontech ist der mercedes unter den
impfstoffen und moderner ist der rolls
royce in bezug auf die sehr seltene
nebenwirkungen die unter zehn fällen pro
100.000 liegen das sind beide äquivalent
und auch bei antec und moderner mission
sei kein thema es konnten wir einen
studien zeigen dass die sogenannte kreuz
impfung sogar immunologische vorteile
bieten kann ostern läuft gut die
nachfrage hat die bundesregierung kalt
erwischt piontek vorübergehend
rationieren heißt auch genug für junge
leute zu reservieren für die moderne
wegen seltener heftiger impfreaktionen
nicht empfohlen wird ich würde auch
moderne oder so nehmen einfach nur damit
gemacht ist es richtig booster schlangen
wie hier in mainz aber genug für alle
piontek kündigte heute eine million
zusätzlicher impfdosen nächste woche an
50 millionen bei montech und moderner
sind bis jahresende sowieso gesichert
dann schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
zahlen rund um corona das robert koch
institut hat in deutschland binnen eines
tages 30
1643 neuinfektionen registriert das sind
7036 mehr als am vergangenen montag
die sieben tage incidents liegt nun bei
386,5 das rk ii spricht von einer
bundesweiten hospitalisierung rate von
5,28 der wert gibt an wie viele kurven
19 erkrankte pro woche und pro 100.000
einwohner ins krankenhaus mussten die
fälle werden allerdings oft erst spät
gemeldet
für die cdu ist es fast schon routine
die partei sucht mal wieder einen neuen
chef nur das wie ist eine absolute
premiere jedes der rund 400.000
mitglieder darf nämlich mit abstimmen
vor rund einer stunde hat das
schaulaufen der kandidaten offiziell
begonnen friedrich merz stellt sich vor
norbert röttgen und helge braun sind
diese woche auch noch dran über das
experiment eines traums
friedrich merz macht den auftakt per
livestream stellt er sich als erster der
drei kandidaten den fragen der
cdu-mitglieder gute chancen hat er bei
der basis kommt er an und die hat
diesmal das sagen das image des
konservativen will abstreifen sein ziel
kein rechtsruck sondern volkspartei ich
bin eher weil man es ein großer
befürworter des prinzips volkspartei das
heißt wir wollen in der partei zur
politischen mitte hin integrieren und
nicht klientel partei werden zuvor hatte
sich kandidat helge braun der
hauptstadtpresse präsentiert bislang
angela merkels kanzleramtsminister das
profil der partei will r schärfen die
soziale seite mehr herausstellen aber
auch beim thema innere sicherheit
nachlegen als mann der mitte will er
zeigen dass wir gemeinsam stark sind
dass die cdu eine union ist und dass wir
die verschiedenen strömungen wir haben
wieder als stärke begreifen und nicht
als gegeneinander und deshalb so ein
wort wie lager müssen aus dem
sprachgebrauch der cdu streichen er
stichelt gegen mitbewerber märz ohne den
zu nennen frauen sehr braun nicht nur
als stellvertreterin vera bühler
frischgebackene bundestagsabgeordnete
und tochter eines bergmanns schlägt er
als generalsekretär in vor wenn sie so
wollen brauchen wir einen neuen stil
einen neuen stil der verbindlichkeit
verlässlichkeit und menschlichkeit und
einer sprache die nicht nur akademiker
sondern jedermann versteht nadine schön
bundestagsabgeordnete aus dem saarland
soll die parteiarbeit reformieren die
cdu zur mitmachpartei wandeln helge
braun als auch der dritte kandidat
norbert röttgen werden sich im lauf der
woche den mitgliedern im internet
vorstellen die können dann bis zum 16
dezember abstimmen wer parteichef werden
sollen
es gibt eine bemerkenswerte nachricht
heute von der bundesbank die rechnet
weiter mit rasant steigenden
verbraucherpreisen konkret mit knapp
sechs prozent inflation im laufenden
monat öl und spritpreise spielen dabei
genauso eine rolle wie wirtschaftliche
sondereffekte die erst ende des jahres
auslaufen aber auch danach könnte die
teuerung für längere zeit über drei
prozent liegen befürchtet die bundesbank
die flucht über das mittelmeer sie geht
weiter fast 60.000 menschen haben in
diesem jahr versucht italien und damit
europa zu erreichen
und viele werden auf ihrer gefährlichen
route gerettet wie von der privaten
organisation sea watch fast 500 menschen
hat sie seit ende vergangener woche an
bord genommen jetzt warten sie auf einen
sicheren hafen zum anlegen
jetzt zu einer tragödie im us
bundesstaat wisconsin aus dem nichts
rast plötzlich ein geländewagen mitten
in die menge fünf menschen sterben mehr
als 40 werden verletzt auf einer parade
wollten sie die vorweihnachtszeit feiern
der mutmaßliche fahrer des wagens konnte
festgenommen werden benjamin daniel zum
stand der ermittlungen
diese aufnahme zeigt die geschwindigkeit
mit der der suv fahrer in die parade
raster in einer anderen einstellung
sieht man wie ein kind nicht ahnen nur
zentimeter dem tod entgeht amerika
versucht zu begreifen was da gestern in
der kleinstadt waukesha im us
bundesstaat wisconsin passiert ist
ich habe direkt vor mir gesehen wie drei
menschen angefahren wurde
andere sind gekommen und haben versucht
sie wiederzubeleben
da lagen so fälle auf dem boden java
blut das war furchtbar
bisher sickerten hinweise durch die
nahelegen dass sich der fahrer wohl auf
der flucht befand es soll um eine
messerstecherei gegangen sein die
polizei ermittelt in alle richtungen
durch den geländewagen wurden mehrere
paraden teilnehmer getötet weitere
verletzt darunter auch kinder
ich bin erschüttert dass so viele zur
parade gekommen sind und nun mit
verletzungen und gebrochenen herzen zu
kämpfen haben
die familie sind bei dieser tragödie das
wichtigste wir müssen uns jetzt um die
betroffenen und deren angehörige kümmern
diese familien brauchen jetzt unser
aller bei statt
die aufklärung des ereignisses hat erst
begonnen viele fragen sind noch offen
klar ist allerdings schon jetzt diesen
21 november werden die menschen in
waukesha noch lange verarbeiten müssen
jetzt nach bulgarien dem ärmsten land
der eu dort ist der sozialist rubén rada
für fünf weitere jahre zum präsidenten
gewählt worden mit einem klaren ergebnis
von fast 67 prozent bei der stichwahl
der 58 jährige gilt als symbolfigur im
kampf gegen die korruption im land
bulgarien steht vor großen problemen wie
etwa einer heftigen vierten corona welle
und einer drohenden wirtschaftskrise
und zurück nochmals zum thema corona als
vergangenes jahr in deutschland die
ersten maßnahmen im kampf gegen das
virus eingeführt wurden regte sich vor
allem in baden württemberg protest
selbst ernannte querdenker gingen auf
die straßen jetzt hat eine studie
beleuchtet wer diese menschen dort sind
und was sie bewegt das ergebnis alle
eint ein tiefes misstrauen gegenüber dem
staat und ihre wurzeln hat diese
bewegung er im linksalternativen milieu
dazu eva schiller
ihre überzeugungen sind radikal die zahl
der querdenken anhänger ist klein aber
sie sind laut stark was verbindet die
demonstranten in baden württemberg wo
die querdenken bewegung wurzelt das
ergebnis der nicht repräsentativen
studie lautet es sind vor allem
esoterisch und anthroposophisch
eingestellte menschen mit eher hohem
bildungsniveau und vor allem ehemalige
grünen und linke wähler haben sich in
baden württemberg den querdenkern
angeschlossen während in ostdeutschland
die extreme rechte eine größere rolle
spiele sind eben menschen die eine ganz
bürgerliche eigenverantwortliche
lebensführung
praktizieren sich jetzt aber vom staat
gegängelt fühlen wobei auch viele
esoterische aspekte eine rolle spielen
wie gespalten aber auch dieses
alternativen milieu ist zeigt sich in
der praxis von tobias peselmann einem
kinderarzt in freiburg er setzt auf
anthroposophische grundsätze auf
selbstbestimmung und ganzheitlichkeit
und es trotzdem gegen korona geimpft
jetzt versucht er seinen vielen
skeptischen patienten ängste zu nehmen
also ein häufiges argument ist natürlich
dass man gesagt hat die impfung ist sehr
schnell entwickelt worden die andere
angst ist das es immer wieder auch noch
menschen gibt die auch sagen ja gutes
hat auch sicher irgendwelche
nebenwirkungen da versuche ich natürlich
die menschen zu beruhigen und auch ein
stück weit davon zu überzeugen und ihnen
auch diese bedenken zu nehmen wenn
eltern masken atteste für ihre
eigentlich gesunden kinder fordern dann
lehnt er ab denn wie gefährlich ein
falsches attest sein kann zeigt sich an
dieser nahgelegenen waldorfschule nach
einem corona ausbruch mit dutzenden
infizierten stellt die schulaufsicht
fest 50 masken atteste waren ungültig
in österreich gilt seit heute ein
dreiwöchiger lockdown für alle also auch
für geimpfte die menschen dürfen nur
noch aus triftigen grund ihr zuhause
verlassen erlaubt sind der weg zur
arbeit einkaufen für den täglichen
bedarf oder auch der aufenthalt im
freien zur erholung die schulen bleiben
offen eltern können entscheiden ob sie
ihre kinder in den unterricht schicken
und ab kommendem februar soll außerdem
eine allgemeine impfpflicht gelten
es ist fast ende november normalerweise
wenn jetzt überall die weihnachtsmärkte
öffnen aber glühwein trinken und
gemeinsam feiern vielen städten ist das
derzeit einfach zu riskant markt um
markt wurde abgesagt brandenburg will es
zumindest mit etwas weihnachtsstimmung
versuchen ab heute unter zweig
bedingungen wenn auch nur bis übermorgen
es sind eben besondere zeiten
angeblichen bei
freudige erwartung heute morgen auf dem
potsdamer weihnachtsmarkt die
schausteller öffnen ihre buden hoffen
auf ein gutes geschäft alles ist
vorbereitet ja na klar die stollen
werden schon im juli august sie backen
und wenn wir jetzt nicht verkaufen
können wäre natürlich für alle
beteiligten schaden strenge kontrollen
nur wer geimpft oder genesen ist hat
zugang zum markt
[Musik]
während die gäste trotz der
beschränkungen ihren glühwein genießen
verbreitet sich unter den händlern die
enttäuschende nachricht schon am
mittwoch soll der markt wieder schließen
auch in brandenburg steigen die inzidenz
'nen zu stark an
früher reagieren können in meinen augen
viel früher das hätte gar nicht
aufgebaut werden müssen und vor allem
fehlt mir eine einheitliche linie als
unternehmer in dieser ganzen grüner
politik wir haben ja fünf angestellte
wir müssen die entlassen ja und wie es
für uns persönlich privat weitergeht das
ist alles dafür dass städten entstehen
die halle zu hause ist voll und so war
das jetzt alles weg kippen oder das sind
ja wahnsinnige werte was machen wir
jetzt damit brandenburg hat jetzt die
notbremse gezogen
auch dieses weihnachtsfest wird in
deutschland anders sein als viele
gehofft haben
wir sind beim sport wir sind bei kristin
oder sind bei personalsorgen im
champions league woche immerhin borussia
dortmund muss zum beispiel vorläufig
ohne stürmer torres auskommen der trotz
impfung positiv auf corona getestet
wurde bei den bayern muss julian
nagelsmann am fünften spieltag der
königsklasse sogar auf acht profis
verzichten fünf davon sind in quarantäne
sportlich läuft es in der champions
league bayern als gruppensieger bereits
qualifiziert für das achtelfinale aber
corona macht sorgen mindestens acht
spieler nicht dabei der meister reist
mit einem rumpfkader
der trainer bleibt trotzdem optimistisch
acht ausfälle ist nicht so dass wir uns
mit irgendeiner theken truppe anreisen
sehr sehr gute mannschaft nach der
bundesliga niederlage in augsburg und
zwei gegentoren der meister aus auf
wiedergutmachung und das wohl ohne
marcel sabitzer der droht auszufallen
wegen verletzung aber auch smartrac wir
eine kleine gruppe mit direkter
ansprache
wenig gespräch im hotel wenn nicht
spielt das ist auch ganz angenehm die
bayern auf champions league tour gern
tief und wohl auch auf der suche nach
der verlorenen leichtigkeit
alle partien und alle tore des zwölften
bundesliga spieltages können sie sich
bei uns noch einmal ganz in ruhe
anschauen wie gewohnt online ausführlich
zusammengefasst auf zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app
store diese frage bleibt weiterhin
unbeantwortet auch nach dem telefonat
des ioc chefs mit der verschwundenen
chinesischen tennis spielerinnen nach
dieser video schalte des ioc präsidenten
thomas bach mit der vermissten
tennisspielerin porsche wird der
widerstand weltweit größer in seinem
verhalten beweist thomas war einmal mehr
dass er nicht gewillt ist den
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china sei
es gegenüber ganz nationalitäten oder
einzelnen personen zwei einhalt zu
gebieten die sportvereinigung global es
sieht schreibt in einer stellungnahme
das ioc hat erneut bewiesen dass es
athleten im stich lässt an der seite von
gewaltsamen autoritären regimen steht
und menschenrechte ignoriert und fordert
für punkt erneut die suspendierung von
chinas olympischen komitee
große empörung wir bleiben da dran dann
sage ich danke schön diese woche eher
ruhiges spätherbst werte aber hier und
da auch ein bisschen schnee gibt's
gleich von katja honnefer später um
21.45 spricht marietta slomka im heute
journal mit winfried kretschmann den
grünen ministerpräsident von baden
württemberg auch über dessen plädoyer
für eine impfpflicht wir vom 19 uhr
heute team sagen danke schön abend und
gerne bis morgen um 7
[Musik]
guten abend heute hat es geschneit
zumindest in den bergen weit oben zum
beispiel im schwarzwald aber auch der
schwäbischen alb am alpenrand im
thüringer wald und im erzgebirge für
viele gab es aber auch mal wieder
strahlenden sonnenschein hier in
norddeutschland das wetter das jetzt auf
uns zukommt macht sich schon über der
nordsee bemerkbar die ersten
regenschauer kamen schon heute
nachmittag an und auch jetzt in der
nacht gibt es etwas regen an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee songs bleibt es in
norddeutschland meist stärker bewölkt
richtig klaren himmel sehen sie dagegen
in der mitte und am alpenrand fällt noch
etwas regen oder schneeregen wenn es
klar als da wird es sehr kalt dann
sinken die temperaturen auf frostige
minus drei bis minus fünf grad das
wasser hält etwas wärmer deswegen liegen
die tiefsttemperaturen an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee bei 6 bis 3 grad morgen
sind es in norddeutschland meist do 8
bis 10 grad meist aber bleibt es doch
mit zwei bis sieben grad deutlich kälter
in norddeutschland wird das morgen eher
ein trüber tag es gibt ein bisschen
nieselregen und die sonne beschränkt
sich doch meist auf die küsten von nord-
und ostsee im süden ist es freundlicher
da scheint die sonne zum teil strahlend
wenn ich gerade nebel und hochnebel
stören das kann mal länger der fall sein
am mittwoch und donnerstag ändert sich
wenig aber am freitag kommt dann aus den
alpen der erste schnee heran
wahrscheinlich auch im flachland guten
abend